Okay, okay, okay. Let us know
in the comments
if you think that lava lamps
are cultural appropriation.
Cut. As always, good effort.
Some positive news,
the company’s expanding
medical coverage,
so you should all have insurance
by the end of the quarter.
What does that mean?
Really, Hannah?
Okay, Doctor Ryan, explain
to me medical insurance.
Medical insurance is ...
It’s insurance
that you need for-
Nice. Hannah, can you
not bully Ryan?
He can’t help that he’s
the [bleep] of the group.
Now, these policies
are very specific,
so I want you
to make sure you read
every word
of these packets,
including the fine print
and Braille.
Pass.
You’re here early.
Yeah. I didn’t go to sleep yet.
My doctor just started me
on 50 milligrams of Vyvanse.
It’s like Adderall on speed.
I read this book twice,
I wrote a screenplay
and I organized
my barbecue collection.
Are you sure that our insurance
covers psychiatric care?
Doctor Cleo isn’t a psychic.
She’s legit.
My insurance card is actually
like a Six Flags VIP pass.
For drugs.
So you didn’t have to pay
for your Vyvanse?
I just show the pharmacy my card
and they give me
whatever I want.
I’m never taking
this thing off.
’Sup, geezers?
Hey. Whoa! Hannah, what happened
to your face?
Preventative Botox. This is
just the initial swelling.
Doctor said it’ll go down
in like three weeks.
Where did you go?
A pop-up. In the back of a van.
Are you sure you went
to a real doctor?
Yes, Nate. I’m not an idiot.
Our insurance covered it.
Can you believe
I didn’t have to pay a dime?
Yes.
I don’t think that our insurance
covers Botox.
Did you not read page
11 of the packet?
I don’t know, that seems wrong.
Exactly, it’s insurance.
How’s it going down there?
Jesus, Jordan.
Are you okay?
If by ’okay’ you mean ’tall’,
then I am better than okay.
By four inches exactly.
Took a lot of stretching
and implants,
but I will be good to go
in about 37 rehab visits.
Where’d the extra bones
come from?
My dad donated them.
What happened to him?
He’s just shorter now.
Jordan, height is
a pre-existing condition.
Page 36, read the packet, Nate.
You guys all read
that big-ass packet?
I can’t even get you
to read my emails.
That’s because
they offer us nothing.
I found an experimental doctor
that gives humans
reptile features.
There are rats
in the walls.
Do snake eyes allow you
to sense heat now or something?
Oh no, I now there are rats
in the walls
because I put them there.
My snake eyes are actually
purely cosmetic.
Okay, seems clear to me
that you are all cheating
the system in various ways.
It’s at least good to know
that we have full coverage.
Full coverage?
No, we’re just lucky that all
our procedures are unnecessary.
Sir?
Huh?
Hey. Buddy, I just got word
that your insurance company
does not cover
emergency appendectomies,
so I’m going to have
to put this bag
of poison
back inside of you.
But it’s already out.
I don’t make the rules, sir.
Didn’t your employee provide you
with an information packet?
I was busy reading the emails.
So many emails.
Do I still have to do
this?